oh my gosh yeah oh they I saw to the
lens when I'll be yeah so we've just got
to David's house flip don't just get
seep those right there you see those get
seat though it seems little cheese on
joy used to call Keith because you built
a seat though yeah right here at work
out here cuz we're planning on going out
for a walk with this David yeah David
hasn't been answering Casey and I got
here about 20 minutes ago
and Dave I'm winded already just cling
up those stairs I'm so not in shape it's
like this morning David supposedly had
jiu-jitsu class did you guys try calling
so funny because David set this whole
thing up we're all waiting on him never
joining him yeah yes baby actually you
think we've been inviting us for some
time to go out for walks around the
neighborhood David organised this thing
in anything even here in his own thing
oh you're calling me love you this
calling me good morning
all right look who finally decided to
show up I know there's a parking lot
that I always Park at I lost my parking
ticket and then so you have to go to the
front but the parking attendant was gone
and the person that managed the fight
alone was gone too I said they were out
for lunch and so I'm just sitting there
like thirty minutes they stopped then my
battery guys on my phone so I was like
this is like the worst situation ever
and then finally when I charged up two
percent I give you a phone nothing now
we're ready to go I don't believe you
David
[Music]
[Music]
that's Joe's warmup I like it it's so
fun it's so Joe trying to warm up and I
pan over to you it's like very happy
really I'm doing that the Asian grandma
warm up right now Sami stretch there we
go the whole walk here with a warm up to
then right yes funny I can't put my hair
up in a ponytail because it's so short
and so I decided to just tuck it behind
my ears I'm like just tuck it inside the
Hat and it turned over I was like I look
like I have a mullet at home what do you
think
do I have a mullet I think it looks high
of your training if I matrix Trinity for
matrix yeah with the add-on she has
black hair though
yeah but one yeah hopefully it doesn't
get in my face while we play tennis
we're gonna play tennis Jessica yeah you
know I've never played so would you mind
just being patient with me what do you
mean - you play tennis in high school
would I know I wasn't good ever I was
never good first time playing tennis
[Music]
to follow review the other one went over
the fence in the street I'm not good at
this little rabbit you know it's funny
as soon as you turn on the camera all
the times that I'm trying to hit the
ball I keep missing because before the
camera was rolling I was hitting with
you I'm not that better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nobody handed
that's a constant eye in
careful don't finish it
[Music]
Oh
from the table Oh a sandwich
they're saying for our food would you
get turkey club I always tell it's if I
find sandwiches that the most boring and
booth in the world and the blend is food
in the world it's kind of like and oh
yeah I'm looking at it I'm like this
might change my mind about sandwiches
this place and we found when I had one
sandwich I created about to get what it
was
hi I'm exaggerating I'm sure you guys
but it's over
means away
[Music]
elastic looking burner
[Music]
this is the best damn sandwich I've ever
had in my life
oh that's like a huge every Friday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna Jacuzzi no it's like she
knows that I'm allergic inside yeah but
get you all far as we take you bed good
night good night put it in the bag
[Music]
hey so we just got home and we are
starting Isaac's project alright so I'm
not sure about other states but in the
state of California every fourth grader
needs to make like a California project
usually or at least from when I was in
fourth grade it was all about missions
so like you know like the missions that
we have in California so I remember
making my project on a mission but I
forgot which mission I picked and I
actually made the model of it and I
built it all out and so this time around
I forgot to choose his own topic for his
California project and one of those
topics that he could have picked which
he picked was early Hollywood and so he
has to do like a three part thing the
first part is like a written report the
second part is a project that you create
it could be like a poster board or a
photo album or a model of some sort and
I just decided to do a model of the
Hollywood sign and so we bought all this
stuff today and then the last part it's
the oral report which is gonna be all
hand where nice move would help him with
that but right now we're working on his
model and we got all the supplies we
went to Michael's today what you're
working on now clean your planes but
that evening all the work oh yeah we got
Chaplin playing on the background to get
into the mood of early Hollywood we got
the kid I'm helping with the palm trees
my pipe cleaner palm trees we were
contemplating whether to buy the models
the model stuff yet or to make her own
and yeah that's better
yeah my palm trees I'm gonna be making
some more countries that she's very good
how do you feel about it being older now
with these projects but these projects
to me it's like he's getting older I
know
I know and it's so crazy to remember
like me doing the fourth grade projects
like stop slow down time slow to town
we've been working on this project late
nights for so long II you have some
really deep dark circles baby all right
you know my poor baby everything someone
to work into this project
look at those tired to feel like that is
doing most of it we got our you in a
charge Chaplin movie I'm gonna keep
making more of these at palm trees all
right so I think we're good with the
hill we're gonna paper mache this you're
gonna do our paper mache mix and
according to a quick Google search we're
gonna do the cook method
[Music]
all right we made one big couch looking
someone was thinking this red couch just
sat on your project would you be mad if
they just sat on your project
all right so this is part one tonight
and then tomorrow night
part two yeah yep everything else
[Music]
all right they - they - he killed you
just wanna mix half-and-half blue and
white together so it's a nice sky loop
sonic Bob rock walls
[Music]
why are all painters French so the most
famous painters are actually Spanish and
I know that
[Music]
the patchy green couch yeah patchy brown
couch for the really tore up green
blanket
[Music]
you never look more like a Hollywood
Walk of Fame for the red paper even
though I know the real one is black
there's something about red just thinks
it feels more like Hollywood on what do
you think - okay right I'm the parent
that over thinks all the kids projects
we don't have as much time like this
thing is due soon to be the party pooper
producer yeah you're the producer you're
there you're the you're the money man
you friended the although all the
supplies here you're the producer I'm
the crazy director that's trying to like
it's got to be more realistic guys Isaac
how'd you feel about the project when
the teacher first assigned it where you
like yes project time where you're like
oh my god in class before like man this
is the nether another cousin minecraft
the nether is basically h-e-l-l-o they
call it this is Sol another is it is it
the nether for you though oh we started
down like this I don't like it
but now since I see it I feel proud how
do you feel mommy I'm so proud we've
accomplished I know I'm pretty proud too
it feels good when everything comes
together yeah honestly yesterday from
ashame I was like I don't know what this
is gonna look like guys I think we might
have messed over her head
but it's actually really good all right
final touches who's that right there
Isaac Charlie Chaplin Charlie Chaplin
there we go nice Charlie Chaplin's got
the moustache in that and then R away
from Marilyn Monroe de drie mm-hmm her
hair's still wet from the shower yeah
I'm actually very very proud of this -
Isaac he's not even my grade in Jersey
[Music]
that is gorgeous I want to do a stop
motion now and I want to make a move how
they cool film a second
[Music]